[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing for
Wednesday May 10th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
on Tuesday Virgin Galactic said it's on
track to send its first commercial
flight into orbit in late June that's
good news for the company which hasn't
sent a crude mission to space in nearly
two years when its billionaire founder
Richard Branson went up it also reported
a net loss last quarter of 159 million
dollars but attributed it mostly to
investments in developing its current
and future Fleet Virgin Galactic has had
plenty of delays and hurdles to deal
with so what comes next
joining me to talk about it is wsj
Aerospace reporter Micah maidenberg
Micah Virgin Galactic says it's been
working on upgrades and improvements to
its vehicle system that uses a plane to
carry a spaceship to the edge of space
is there anything specific about that
system that's caused delays so you're
right the company's method for getting
to the edge of spaces not a rocket they
use this specialized space plane so to
speak to carry up a spaceship which
unlatches from the plane and then shoots
into the kind of edge of space and then
Glides back down you know from Landings
and that's the kind of system that the
company has been using and developing
for many years at this point during that
time various dates for launching
commercial service have come and go and
the company has faced some challenges
with getting those Vehicles set and
proven out that they can carry people to
the edge of space and bring them back
safely now of course that's happened
multiple times now including with the
flight with Richard Branson in 2021 but
look with space vehicle developments
delays are are not uncommon and Virgin
Galactic dealt with a number of delays
itself can you tell us about some of
those delays so for example and just as
a reminder to listeners Richard
Branson's virgin group founded Virgin
Galactic almost 20 years ago in 2004 but
during that time as it worked itself and
with Partners to develop these vehicles
it did face challenges an engine test
for example in 2013 resulted in an
explosion no one was heard in that but
that's something they had to deal with
and then the following year in 2014
during a test flight conducted by an
outside company one of the Prototype
spaceships that was being used at the
time broke apart and crashed after a
co-pilot later made what a safety
official said was an error and that
killed him that also delayed kind of
development and the company's plans to
sort of launch commercial service which
they say you know years on now that
they're poised to do by the end of June
what has virgin said about all these
technical problems well virgin since the
Richard Branson flight in July of 2021
has been pretty heads down and focused
on bolstering the plane that it has
right now the carrier plane and the one
spaceship that it has it says it's taken
a number of steps to sort of upgrade
those strengthen them prepare them for a
more regular you know fight Cadence
Virgin Galactic has already sold some
tickets to space tourists how are they
reacting to all of these delays the
company has talked about this
reservation list that it's had for a
number of years now and you know look
some of those passengers have aged out
you know they have for one reason the
other decided to move on for example I
spoke to a retiree who told me he had
basically reserved a seat in 2007 and it
hoped to be flying within five years
from that time he didn't get to make it
he decided to drop out in 2018 11 years
after he had reserved that seed because
of a medical condition now the company
has said that at the end of last year
they had around 800 reservations and
some customers who dropped off last year
were generally backfilled so it'll be
interesting to see what the reservation
list looks like how big it is but
clearly some customers have missed their
chance to fly I want to ask you about a
separate but maybe related issue virgin
orbit Branson's other space company
filed for bankruptcy last month can you
just remind listeners who maybe heard
about that how these two companies
relate and if the issues at virgin orbit
is facing will have any impact on Virgin
Galactic yeah yeah first thing to know
is that Virgin Galactic and virgin orbit
are completely separate companies they
have different management teams
different markets that they're targeting
different employee bases different
technology however they do share a
common history
2017 Virgin Galactic officials announced
that virgin orbit would spin out and
develop a small satellite launching
system to deploy some all satellites
into orbit and that would be a separate
company that would be distinct from
Virgin Galactic virgin orbit has as you
mentioned faced some challenges and
filed for bankruptcy the company wasn't
able to execute a launch recently from
the UK and the small satellite launching
Market is very tough you know a lot of
like launch Executives have talked about
only one or two
small sat launchers making it the
general Trend in rocket development has
been to develop larger vehicles that can
take more satellites to orbit at once
and in that context version orbits
business model face some real real
difficulties and real challenges we've
been talking about Virgin Galactic are
the problems that they're facing being
dealt with by any of their private space
competitors for example blue origin
which was started by Jeff Bezos yeah
look the summer of 2021 was a very high
profile kind of moment for call it
sub-orbital private space flights
Richard Branson made it there Jeff Bezos
got there on Blue origin and it's always
been seen as a very nascent industry
this has never happened before for
decades human space flight has been the
domain of government space agencies and
these companies saw their suborbital
space flights as a way to change that
Dynamic both have had challenges you
know since those flights in September of
last year blue origin during a research
Mission without anybody on board
experienced an engine nozzle failure
that destroyed one of its vehicles and
the company has not flown anyone to
space since that time and of course
Virgin Galactic has not conducted any
any space flights since taking Mr Ranson
and others up almost two years ago so
people say all the time space is hard
delays are common and both Virgin
Galactic and blue origin have faced some
challenges in building out the
businesses they're hoping to build out
that's our reporter Micah maidenberg
thanks for joining us okay thanks so
much Zoe and that's it for today's
for more Tech story
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]